-Guys, today was
such a historic day,
and there were so many
iconic images and headlines.
But, sometimes, when you see
a photo in the news,
you think that headline
could be much better.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for "News & Improved:
Inauguration Edition."
-♪ "News & Improved" ♪
-For example,
check out this first photo.
The original headline was...
The headline can
definitely be improved,
'cause if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been...
See how that works?
Alright, let's check out
this next photo.
The original headline was...
But if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been...
It's like,
"Where's the button? What..."
Up next, this headline says...
The headline
could have been...
This next headline was...
But the headline
could have been...
This next headline was...
The headline
could have been...
Score!
And, finally,
this headline says...
But the headline
could have been...
Well, that's all the time
we have for
"News & Improved," everybody.